okay [ __ ] okay we are doing this
mission x8 high school horror travel to
the x8 Research Center it's your boy
psych eval here with with kanye west
right here very happy to be here very
happy to be nominated just very grateful
you know and again i got this dog a gun
and there's a shitton anime so shut all
right just sucking dry it and I like I
thought I was done with this high school
job but I guess anything here like no no
nothing here so I'm not [ __ ] me I
just got a [ __ ] bullet in the side ok
got good
[ __ ] it that is it graves yeah shell
Jesus I'm wearing at the show show okay
betcha I know you're here yeah are they
chase us yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] me I can
oh no that was a valid but let me keep
moving [ __ ] I got to go all the way over
there okay [ __ ] it where is this guy Wow
yeah that's nothing scary gonna like an
ass is [ __ ] me I don't [ __ ] know
this is a shut okay it's all red it's a
[ __ ] water oh man you [ __ ] I can't
see ya gotta get her out clothes come on
get him again
okay okay i'm i am already um tough heck
is this hey man where'd he go I like
that it's a very simple you know level
up
okay okay well anyway that's Cape Cod
put this on I got a little faster you
know [ __ ] just great just what I need
some nutjob firing a tree in the
distance I can't I fashionable naturally
I'm right here and I got to go all over
their recess actually I'll do this and I
will take the like higher up oh ok and
as you weapon let's put that up mm okay
toughness
and again
yeah now
okay here we go okay is it grass its
second disgusting is what that is why do
I feel like short oh it's good some
crouching I was like what the [ __ ] sorry
my language guys I just got very
emotional sometimes of video games like
very emotional Kurt I hear [ __ ] oh great
good old radiation what the [ __ ] is at
yeah it's not gonna sit good yeah I
guess sorry sir you never meant for this
world never meant for this world exit
alameda shut ok is where goes where
we're done
okay that [ __ ] is this like the
auditorium and the ways I think I go a
little faster if i put the gun away and
i miss the sprint feature let me see
something okay okay episode I sorry guys
okay okay
10 i mislike the door so I
exit that [ __ ] okay jay says it's got on
here just got King just gawking yeah god
awesome okay let's see here Wow the [ __ ]
has gone out here
you got the kennel your car is k [ __ ]
a
yeah that's disgusting look at you all
square hello sir anti-gays
guys King season time lock it
what the [ __ ]
yeah at the kennedy you go back
mm-hmm I can helicopters that's like am
i right or am i right
really get out [ __ ] accurate so Jesus
don't mind if I do
ok
have that I know that we got stuff in
here
I feel different awake alive for the
first time ever
I mean these Council yeah you just
[ __ ] killed himself that's cool I
guess bring them that's that for let's
not call it all
yes sir ok I can get back out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here okay there's
some places that what human beings were
just not meant to go
okay okay right level on act level two
okay he's got something like he'll do it
now ok that's what it is this one is
open
students this is the pre-recorded voice
of your principal Chiefs first
researcher fuzzy line c14 later preserve
rattlesnake DNA and put it in the
redditor oh the troll splice enough I
always say especially if you can make a
magnificent enough about me the burden
by your grandfather this is a most
serious requiring the most serious
Oh
oh yeah I like the blanks and his eyes
ah well uh guy okay i'll see ya shed I
[ __ ] here this is pretty interesting
story okay okay
okay I got one jay says I [ __ ] hate
this there's always like a 10 inch small
burn five small bright buck Irish so
many cigarettes are like so many kids
selling cigarettes I can't ok I know how
much you guys love watching ideas so I
Rocco
I hear a pop a and I don't say up have a
okay days okay can I take really good
accuracy hey like so damn crazy
okay she's seeing their cats
that I get that I can
sorry says physics channel I [ __ ] all
right ah thanks dad i'm [ __ ] rock and
crap off
look how [ __ ] take Stan lag is
stairs so hold on right here yeah I got
second disgusting and I got level up
okay let's tear this bitch's ship I
should reload earlier Jesus well I can't
get katka should I see one
I go up around town at school he's the
cool setting icon yeah music sake do not
like that that's for sure ok ok I things
that they're done
and get get oh what the [ __ ] why so many
yeah like that it I could tell
that's getting mixed up okay yeah that's
that
let's see the sonic emitter upgrade
though this is really Lorelai way you
would get okay okay that's a nice gun
what the [ __ ] has gone out here set
stakeout there's a lot of weird [ __ ]
going on here that's all I gonna say
wasn't that shut down for some reason
that's why I replaced his legs with
spare and fed him a steady diet of
psycho ways George on cars k what the
flying [ __ ] all I know is I gotta pop
this sucker oh [ __ ]
ouch area [ __ ] Lana everywhere
getting in here no ain't [ __ ] in here
[ __ ] first day I was on it ok ok let
us get the [ __ ] outta the flying [ __ ]
outta here
okay it says to go this way
to hang his ass
ok
that says shut okay klein watch her all
right back in his room was just shut
this looks [ __ ] heads 07 [ __ ] them up
there okay
failure they'll blow reach one okay
where do I gotta get it out
what is this one
what the [ __ ] okay huh just upgraded
recorded voice of your principal
thanks